Better Call Saul is one of the
best shows on TV right now.
It's as entertaining as it is inventive.
It feels distinct
even in the so-called Golden Age of TV.
When I first heard that Vince Gilligan and the crew
were making a Breaking Bad spinoff centered around a unique but goofy side character
I'll admit I was skeptical
but Better Call Saul has turned out to be something wonderful and amazing in its own right.
And as the third season wraps up
I want to talk about why I think it's such a special show
examining specifically the aspects of the show that
set it apart from most shows on television right now.
This video is free of *major* plot spoilers
but I'll be using examples from Seasons 1 & 2.
[theme music]
I want to start with a quick example of the kind of visual storytelling that
makes me love Better Call Saul.
In the pilot of the show Jimmy McGill our main character
is standing at an elevator and we have no idea where
and we get this wide shot with a
dented trashcan in the foreground.
Jimmy Looks at it so we know it's important
but we don't understand the significance of it yet.
The scene progresses and we find ourselves in this huge fancy law firm
where Jimmy seems to know everybody.
They could have introduced this location
with an establishing shot
of Jimmy entering through the front door
but by introducing the scene with Jimmy coming up through the basement on the elevator
we've already contextually started to associate frustration
and possibly anger with this location
even though Jimmy seems friendly with everyone.
As the scene continues, we get a few minutes of dialogue that gives us background about where we are and Jimmy's relationship to these people
HOWARD: That's money for Chuck
Isn't that what you wanted?
JIMMY: A measly 26 grand?
Another short scene updates us on a subplot from the episode without using any dialogue
and then five minutes later
just when we started to forget about it:
[kicking trashcan]
pay off
[denting of trashcan intensifies]
[sad steel guitar]
With a brilliant shot that pulls back
as an amazing reveal
And with just a few more shots they establish the entire context
of a relationship
We learn so much about these two characters' relationship and history visually
that they can say almost nothing to each other.
JIMMY: Couldn't you just -
KIM: No I can't.
And we already understand so much.
This whole sequence uses visuals to establish the fact that Jimmy has a history at this place
He's worked with these people and he's experienced frustrations here in the past
but not a word of exposition is needed.
Probably the most immediately noticeable thing about Better Call Saul
is the uniqueness of its look.
I could spend an entire video talking about the use of wide shots in this show
building upon some of the established visual themes in Breaking Bad.
Wide shots are used to an amazing effect.
In most shows and even in many movies these days
wide shots often serve simply as an establishing shot
but Better Call Saul probably more than any other show I've seen
uses them to their full potential.
In addition to establishing places and settings
super wide shots communicate a sense of aloneness
and they're used for dramatic emphasis
much like a close-up is used in many shows.
Randomly grab an episode of any network crime show or law show off the shelf
and you often end up with scenes that consist of
a wide establishing shot or two or three people talking
followed by a series of over-the-shoulder
medium close-ups.
Better Call Saul a show where many of the characters
are lawyers and paralegals could easily fall into this trap
but they keep the scenes grounded in the world
with these wide and ultra wide shots.
But the use of wide angles - while the most obvious -
isn't the extent of what makes the cinematography special.
They'll often use longer takes,
dynamic blocking
and go the extra mile with location work
to create some incredibly cinematic moments.
Better Call Saul has a slow deliberate pacing that's rarely found on TV.
The very first post-title scene of the show is a quiet awkward courtroom.
The cold open before the title had almost no dialogue
and that's followed up with this:
[awkward slurping]
It's eight minutes from the start of the show until you get a real
audible line of dialogue said by a character on the screen.
This is *usually* the time when pilot episodes are trying to suck you in
with something exciting or intense.
Even Breaking Bad started off with more of a bang.
But Better Call Saul establishes itself from the start
as being more interested in the quieter slower workings
of the characters and the world.
The dramas that are happening within each episode are small compared to those in many other shows
or even compared to Breaking Bad.
Better Call Saul does an excellent job of unfolding those smaller dramas in a way that feels meaningful.
A smaller story isn't less worthy of the screen
it just needs a different lens to view it by.
Better Call Saul gives us that lens by giving the characters the time and the space they need to
live
breathe
and grow.
The creators of the show don't tell us to care about Jimmy McGill
or to start to sympathize with Mike Ehrmantraut
They allow us to see them in action, good and bad
and we can't help but become endeared to them in the process.
But it's not just slow; we also get, when appropriate
excellent use of montages to move us through time quickly.
[smooth af blues]
Shows with rich, fully fleshed-out characters are more common in TV now
but it's still difficult to pull off.
Better Call Saul has very human characters that do things that make sense for them to do
not just what the plot needs next.
Jimmy's relationship with his brother Chuck is an excellent example of this.
[Chuck] You look piqued
Jimmy: I'm fine, please just sit.
Chuck: You're not in trouble
While many viewers dislike Chuck
and tend to side with Jimmy as the protagonist of the show when conflict between them arises
Chuck is treated fairly sympathetically by the show.
Chuck: I understand that you have... [stammering]...
great affection for Jimmy
a great many people do
but PLEASE open your eyes
We can understand his motivations and why he feels the way he does when conflict arises with his brother
and this is true to life.
In life when a rift forms between two people
it can often be hard to place the blame on one of them in particular.
Instead
there often tends to be parts of their personalities
or value systems that are at odds
and the blame is often a matter of perspective.
The show doesn't paint its characters in black and white.
Howard: Give Chuck my love
would you
It's hard to identify a real villain for the show.
The show often lets us see and consider both sides of an issue
Kim: [clobbers Jimmy]
Jimmy: Kim... What?!
Kim: Just drive.
Similarly
Kim and Jimmy's relationship is one that is given very little exposition.
We don't know much about their history together
or even their current status
but we don't need to
because we're shown as much as we need to know to care about them.
Jimmy: Yes Mrs Kettleman, so good of you to return...
a..actually I don't have Mr McGill at the moment, but I know he..
What is Better Call Saul?
A drama?
A comedy?
A crime show?
A courtroom drama?
A thriller?
Better Call Saul often seems to defy definition
existing outside any clear genre label.
It is what it needs to be for any given episode or story beat.
Some of the comedic scenes with Jimmy and the brilliant silent investigative scenes with Mike Ehrmantraut
feel like they could come from two different kinds of shows.
But the scenes never feel dissonant
the comedy never feels out of place and the drama doesn't feel too somber.
It's a balancing act propelled by logical writing that serves the story instead of the genre.
You never get the feeling that they added plot elements to keep it a crime show or a comedy
Better Call Saul is in a very unique position.
We know how it ends before we even start the show.
Sure we don't know the details and there can and will be some twists along the way
but from the very start
the audience knows what Jimmy will become.
They know who Saul Goodman is from Breaking Bad.
But even if they don't, the cold-open flash-forwards from the start of each season
reminds us from the very beginning what the end game is for Jimmy McGill
Saul Goodman is an inevitable future for Jimmy McGill.
Hi I'm Saul Goodman
and I will do the fighting for you!
No charge is too big for me.
when legal forces have you cornered
Better Call Saul!
How many shows announced the outcome in the very title?
Most show titles are a mere hint at the premise
but Better Call Saul is a thematically purposeful show;
it doesn't beat around the bush.
I don't think that all shows should be more upfront and direct about their themes and where they're going
but the fact that Better Call Saul does this
sets it firmly apart in a sea of well-produced TV
It flirts with fatalism in a way that we rarely experience
on the small screen. In this way it's the perfect spinoff and development of Breaking Bad,
It doesn't just happen in the same story universe, it's cut from the same thematic cloth.
Better Call Saul reverse-engineers Breaking Bad.
Where Breaking Bad was about taking you on a journey of learning to hate a character
as they become completely evil
Better Call Saul is about showing you the past of someone
we already know will become a sleazy criminal
and making us feel sympathetic for that character
by showing us what made him become Saul Goodman.
Better Call Saul keeps the viewer in suspense
and I'm not talking about edge-of-your-seat
tension or fear that someone is going to jump out from behind a dumpster.
The writers are pulling you along with a series of overlapping questions and answers.
I think this is a big way they're able to keep the show interesting even though the biggest dramatic question of the show has already
kind of been answered.
By moving the audience's minds off of the question of what happens to Jimmy in the end,
the show lets them focus on how Jimmy gets there.
The writers are comfortable with you as a viewer
being in the dark about something for entire scenes or episodes
and even when the answer is revealed
it doesn't feel like they have to spell it out for you.
Answers are slowly unraveled
like the true nature of Chuck's condition
and it creates an air of mystery that doesn't exist even in many
mystery and crime-solving shows on TV today.
The Creators truly understand "show don't tell"
and watching Better Call Saul feels more like a discovery than being told a story
which for me is a cornerstone of a great experience with TV or film.
Here's an example
In this scene Chuck shows Jimmy how to peel tape off of his wall so that the wood isn't damaged.
Jimmy would rather rip it off quickly but Chuck is careful, methodical and precise, highlighting the differences between the two brothers
Nevertheless
Jimmy is willing to learn Chuck's method and apply it
A whole episode later, we get this scene
and with no dialogue so much is communicated about Jimmy's unconscious desire to fit into his brother's mold
and his conscious rebellion against that.
Better Call Saul is endlessly drawing me in, making me think "what's going on inside that character's head?"
It's hard to rank Better Call Saul, among the many great TV shows right now
but I know it's one of the best. It's consistently fresh, interesting, logical
and with great cinematography, music, rich characters, interesting themes and good writing
I find myself looking forward to where the show will lead
instead of as I do with most shows
just hoping the next season isn't worse than the one before.
TV is an incredible feat;
it's hard to maintain quality
for 40 to 60 or even 100 hours
so when a team is able to pull that off
I can't help but celebrate it.
I'm Thomas Flight
This has been another video for my series Off the Screen.
This is a bit of a longer video so let me know what you think in the comments.
Remember to subscribe if you want to see more content like this and share the video with a friend
if you think they might enjoy it. I'm sorry it's been a little bit longer getting this video to you but I've got a lot
of cool stuff coming soon so stay tuned and I'll see you again soon.